oh sentence he said that um
the first technique that should be
classed as the first technique
is show manucci
and it's show manuccio
just means one
itch
and
it's one of the most difficult ones
a student will find
to become comfortable with
they may find that uh eventually
after a few months
they start to get it and as you get
better and start training with higher
grades other black belts other people
even in queue grades of your own level
um
we find it very difficult to to do
if our uk's wish to be a little bit
difficult
it might not even mean to be difficult
it might just be strong
now
okay i'm not the best artist
but um
i'm going to try and explain
what i mean
oh sensei said
with shamanucci icchio or all the
shamanucci's and mobilizations
he said i initiate
so he would initiate
he would initiate
for some reason that i don't know
um the ikikai
have
well sorry i'll rephrase that
the hombre dojo um what we know is the
aikikai as well
and they have a cutting down from
shamanucci
and i've never asked for a high level
experienced
master
and the only two i know who is still
alive is uh tada sensei
and yamada sensei
so if i ever get the opportunity i'd
like to actually personally ask them
and what they think
why you would do this when i sense he
said
that on chavenucci
he must initiate
when a strike is coming down
he would actually open up and let the
strike go past him he wouldn't uh
try to
stop it match it or beat it
but
there are different things in yoshinkan
tamiki
you know there's so many variations in
like you know around the world now that
um they all have their good
points their weak points
and
i'm not here to say who's whose is the
correct one
i'm just saying that i have the book
that i sense he wrote i said he wrote
two books
stan pranin uh
was kind enough to award me with the
second no scentsy book and the first
page when you open it
so since he's going to talk about um
you know
hiki or chamonix
and his first words are
check the ground around you
so that's quite
strange when you think that you
you open the page and the translation of
the
english translation is going to tell you
about ikea but he first tells you to
check your surroundings and of course
that makes total sense doesn't it
so
why do people have so much trouble with
eko
it's because uh there's a lot of
uncertainty about
what a person should do
so i'm going to tell you the iwama
approach because i've tried to follow
psycency and cytoscenzi
and the way they perform it is
the hand comes out
so nargo initiates it
and you go forward towards okay
if i go sideways
you'll notice that my thumb
is in line with my nose
this is the point where you should have
entered and made contact
with okay's
wrist
once you do that but what you'll see if
you look on youtube and and
i don't know about books
but you'll see that a lot of people are
here they're up here now this thumb is
leveled by forehead
if you get that
then sensei said to me
they could reverse it and get you in
niccio because
your arm is weak up here where here if
they push you can
resist because you're strong
it can come from your center from here
you're past the point of balance
they could win so you're in a who's the
strongest mode
so from
here it's in front of your nose
you then take the elbow or
if you're doing humble style you would
have an open hand
but then be careful that you don't rise
up because as you rise up
even though you're going to take them
down
remember
the higher you go
the weaker your arm
so you're actually reducing the amount
of power that you've got
so you do from here go up
but you do it
as you go over in to the eq position
where you're taking that balance
all right
if you go in too hard and fast it will
push the hands up
naturally
because
clashing together
you'll both be weak
if one is stronger than the other
then it's still a clash and that's not
aikido
i've done this sincerely little drawing
but you may
be able to read and see
okay this is really just to remind you
that you shouldn't go above the nose
level on the first meeting
and there's some words there that you
may wish to
just
read and remember
if you methodically do this over and
over
so that you you offer
you enter it's like a wave
it comes up your chest
like a wave and towards them as you go
forward
as you go forward
excuse the chair groaning um
if you do this you will retain your
power
and then your power because it has
strong power base it can project project
from this point
but you have to remember to catch them
or with open hands you have to make the
circle
so that you
keep together with them
so
i find that uh most people
overcome the omote iccio but when it
comes to the ura ekyo
especially from shamanucci
they
they can't do it it's as if
they're pushing
and the reach
becomes too far
so i'm going to give you an example here
if you've ever stood on a pair of steps
and you're trying to reach something
there's a comfortable
place
on the steps where you can either fix a
light bulb or you can do something
and there's that the next stage is where
your your your maximum stretch
if you're too high on the eq one once
you've come together if the pushing up
or the
or the from here you go to high in the
up
then
that's what happens with the ura you're
not keeping it constant and you're not
keeping it within the circle
of what
things can be achieved same as i'm
talking about being on a step
some steps a ladder or
in the past i've i've been leaning over
a balcony trying to put christmas
decorations up
so i'm trying to give you some for
instance so you know what i'm talking
about you know and you just want to
reach that little bit further
it's not quite comfortable perhaps the
the the banisters are
stopping you
just quite reaching you get on your
tiptoes you reach a bit more it's
uncomfortable but you're
stubborn mind is going to not be
challenged and beaten
and you might do it
but it's the same as the techniques you
might do it
but it won't be comfortable it won't be
within
the realms of
ikey in other words you're the sense of
the technique
and
around it is comfortable
too large and it's not comfortable
anymore
so we've got the stage where you're on
the steps
step ladder step pair of metal steps or
whatever if you're wondering what i mean
by steps
you're comfortably
changing a light bulb or you know
screwing something in and it's all very
comfortable and it's all organized
and then the steps are
not tall enough
or you're over the banisters
and it then takes a little bit more
daring you're stretching your stretching
you can almost
do your work but it's very difficult but
you're gonna keep calm and you're gonna
try to complete it
there's the third stage where
you just know
that it's wrong
[Music]
to try to go
out on the limb
you know
it's it's more than just having a
pressure in your stomach if you're over
a balcony or you know
you're leaning on some steps or you're
trying to reach up to something you know
even if you like me do yoga you can gain
a few inches
but you just
you just know but you're not going to be
beating your ego minds as no i don't
want to go and ask the neighbor if he's
got taller steps or i haven't got time i
want to do it i want to do it now
and you go beyond your
not comfort zone because your comfort
zone can be
when it's easy to do it
or it's difficult but i can do it
it's impossible but you're still gonna
somehow try to achieve it
so these to me are the three points of
echo
and if you want to be able to do er echo
every single time with a really good
feeling then you need to be in the first
stage you need to be in control
on a comfortable base
and not
reach outside
of your sphere
if you do that
and you really really really work on
your sphere
then you'll get it
the problem is with icchio ureikyo is
the sphere
cannot be seen or drawn it's felt
and what happens is people
lack um
they lack confidence you know they get
it it's in the first stages and then
they start to lack competence because
they know
that it feels like it's getting away
from them they're not
really in control anymore they're going
out
that little bit too far
they think that because the person needs
to have balance they have to go
past the limit of what is their natural
comfort
but that means that you took your eye
off the ball for a moment and you went
outside your own sphere perhaps if you
know that there's a weakness coming up
perhaps you should start to curve that
sphere and actually make the sphere
smaller
not larger
perhaps you've got to start thinking
about doing the opposite to what your
mind is saying that you think you have
to do you see the stretch elastic bands
on and on and on and on and on in the
end if the elastic band will stretch
more than you can stretch
then you're defeated
so it's the same with
[Music]
so
you can do a perfectly good aura
as long as you keep it within a sphere
of
a comfort zone
okay you'll have to trust me on this one
until you find that that place once
you've found it you'll be able to do it
99 times out of 100
and you'll wonder
why you felt found it so difficult for
so many years
okay so i hope you've enjoyed this um
ichio
understanding and
please
contact me if you need more information
or perhaps you'd like to join my patreon
site
if you're not already on patreon
and where we go
in depth just like this
film thank you for your time